hey 42 here human beings are unique in
the animal kingdom in many different
ways we have opposable thumbs which we
evolve to play Xbox and operate complex
TV remotes and are disproportionately
large brains have allowed us to do
incredible things like send people to
the moon and invent fortnite
but perhaps the most striking difference
between human beings and our animal
cousins is the way we've been able to
take control of the world around us
we've harnessed natural resources to
power our homes and chop down trees to
make room for the cities that contain
them we've dug deep beneath the Earth in
search of precious metals and gemstones
and we domesticated plants to feed our
ever-growing numbers but it isn't just
Earth that we've shaped to suit our
needs the same goes for other animals
too
since the first time Ancient Man
forcibly parted a Proto chicken from its
unborn child to make his scrambled eggs
we've happily exploited Earth's other
tenants for food warmth labor
entertainment companionship and medical
research
we've even roped them into our walls and
I don't just mean Cavalry Charges and
carrier pigeons
being the endlessly inventive and
occasionally sadistic species that we
are we forced animals to fight for us in
ways that are both fascinating and
horrifying in equal measure including
bombs made of bats pigeon pilots and
explosive rats but before we get into
the ridiculous
we'd better start with the Equine Now
I'm a major proponent of preserving
traditional Customs skills and crafts
kamikoto knives are beautiful tools made
with high quality Japanese steel using
traditional techniques each knife is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee the knives come in
this absolutely stunning heavy-duty Ash
wood box and you know with Chris was
just around the corner this makes the
ideal present kamikoto knives are the
real deal and are used by Michelin star
chefs all over the world using kamikoto
knives has made my meal prep both a
breeze and a really enjoyable task it's
just such a pleasure using a beautiful
tool and a really sharp knife these
Japanese steel knives are razor sharp
and make quick work of whatever you're
chopping I've been loving using them and
they're now the first thing I reach for
whenever I'm in the kitchen kamikoso is
running a massive Black Friday sale
right now and offering my viewers an
extra 50 US dollars off any purchase
with discount code 42. go to
cabicoto.com 42 and help support the
channel thanks to kamikoto for
sponsoring this video arguably the best
known animal associated with Warfare is
the horse thought to have been used as
far back as 4000 BC in the 6 000 years
since we've used horses to carry us into
battle transport our equipment speed up
communications and in a pinch fill our
bellies
horses helped Genghis Khan conquer half
the world in the 13th century and they
were still being used by the Polish Army
to fight off the Nazis in 1939 although
admittedly that didn't go too well still
there's no exaggeration to say that an
armed man on Horseback was the most
devastating weapon in existence for
several Millennia at least
with horses only being phased out during
the second world war when tanks made
them obsolete do you think our trusty
war horses were upset by that turn of
events nay
elephants were also used as Cavalry in
Ancient Warfare first in India around
the 6th Century BC their main function
was to charge and break Enemy Lines
sowing panic and fear along the way as
you can probably imagine they were
incredibly effective a large unit of war
elephants was practically Invincible
unless you happen to know their one
fatal weakness their Achilles trunk a
counter weapon that once deployed will
cause even the bravest war elephant to
drop 18 kilograms of excrement and run
for the Hills
any ideas what that secret weapon might
have been if you guessed War Pig then
one you must have some highly unusual
reading habits and two I'm impressed
as odd as it may sound pigs positively
petrified elephants rendering them
essentially useless
still that seems to have been a fairly
well kept secret because elephants were
still being used as recently as 1987 by
the Iraqi military
dogs have been employed during times of
War for hundreds of years to deliver
messages take part in patrols and even
carry slippers sorry supplies to the
wounded over 50 000 dogs were used in
World War one alone thousands of which
ended up going to the great kennel in
the sky but we've also conscripted our
canine companions in some more creative
and ultimately disastrous ways one of
the most brutal doggy duties dreamed up
by the Soviets during the second world
war was the anti-tank dog
as the name suggests anti-tank dogs were
trained to drop timed explosives
underneath German tanks before
scampering to safety to admire the
fireworks
simple though the idea was carrying it
out in the theater of war was another
matter entirely for one thing the dogs
were often confused by wartime
conditions and would run back to their
handlers bombed in tow with predictably
disastrous consequences
the original plan having failed
spectacularly the Soviets came up with a
new one to use the dogs as unwitting
Kamikaze Fighters armed with explosives
that would detonate as soon as they were
released killing the dog and whatever
happens to be nearby if this is how man
treats his best friends I'd hate to see
what we do to our worst enemies
still the dogs had the last laugh
they'd naturally been trained on Soviet
tanks but unlike the petrol guzzling
tanks used by the Germans the Soviet
models ran on diesel in the Heat and
confusion of battle the dogs relied on
their sense of smell to navigate and
more often than not they headed straight
for the comforting familiar smell of
Soviet diesel
nobody's quite sure exactly how many
tanks were destroyed by Soviet anti-tank
dogs friendly or otherwise but the
program was quietly muffled in 1943
after many mortifying mishaps
like most Americans dentist little Adams
was incensed by the Japanese attack on
Pearl Harbor and he spent much of his
spare time dreaming up ways the USA
could wreak her revenge unlike most
Americans though little had a direct
connection to the White House via Helena
Roosevelt the first lady which is how he
managed to get a letter through to the
president of the United States which
contained an audacious plan that must
have been just crazy enough to get the
president backing because it initiated
one of the most bizarre projects of the
entire War
this confounding Contraption is a bat
bomb a 1.5 meter long bomb containing
1040 compartments each holding a tiny
amount of Napalm and something far
scarier
small but mighty Mexican free-tailed bat
the idea was that the bomb would be
dropped from a play shedding its casing
when a parachute controlled descent
began at a height of 1 200 meters
having served their time in Bat
Purgatory the furry inmates would
suddenly find themselves free to go
wherever they pleased taking their tiny
Napalm payloads with them
as far as Weapons go the bat bomb was
fittingly but insane
but it was also kind of ingenious
Japanese houses are traditionally built
of Highly combustible materials like
wood and paper so fire was a major
threat and whilst regular incendiary
bombs could have been used instead the
bat bomb was far more devastating the
bats payloads are on timers and once
they went half they'd set fire to
whatever was nearby by that point the
bats would have spread out over the
entire city and many of them would be
happily roosting in hard to reach but
highly flammable hiding places like the
roofs of old buildings by the time
anyone realized what was going on there
would be hundreds of fires raging all
over the city
unlike the anti-tank dog disaster the
batbomb genuinely worked a fact that was
proven spectacularly when one was
accidentally set off in the middle of
Carlsbad Army Airfield in New Mexico
joint testing
bats armed of Napalm was soon flying
around all over the place setting fires
and roosting in the most awkward hard to
reach places
including underneath a fully loaded fuel
tank yeah the ensuing explosion
destroyed the entire testing area
subsequent slightly more controlled
tests showed the bat bomb to be
incredibly effective and the ingenious
weapon May well have seen active servers
had the program been completed just a
little bit earlier in the end though the
bat bomb wasn't declared ready for
action until 1945. by which point the
Americans had invented a different kind
of bomb
of the atomic variety when a single
doomsday device can level an entire city
in one explosion painstakingly gluing
tiny Parcels of Napalm to a thousand
Mexican bats suddenly felt like a waste
of time another American citizen Keen to
lend a hands to the war effort was
renowned behavioral psychologist
inventor and Patriot Boris Skinner who
in 1943 aims to solve the problem of
missiles missing their targets at the
time electronic guidance was in its
infancy and therefore both unreliable
and expensive and that's where project
pigeon came in
Skinner had experienced training pigeons
in his psychological research and he had
a hunstad they'd be surprisingly well
suited to war not only do pigeons have
good eyesight but they remain remarkably
unflappable even the most tumultuous of
circumstances as anyone who's tried to
shoe a pigeon away from their sandwich
in the park will already know
it's going to plan to make use of these
Admiral attributes by training Our
Feathered Friends as Pilots
he designed a specially fitted missile
nose cone with a tiny cockpit big enough
to house up to three pigeons
Each of which will be positioned in
front of a live video feed of whatever
Target needed blowing up
the pigeons had been conditioned to Peck
whichever part of the screen contains
the Target in return for a few seeds
depending on where they packed cables
attached to their heads would feed
information back to the flight control
system which would make the necessary
adjustments automatically if the missile
started to go off course sadly the
projectiles weren't fitted with ejector
seats so a pigeon Pilot's first mission
would also be its last
the first demonstration of the guidance
system was successful but the program
was terminated in October 1944 as all
Focus moved to the Manhattan Project and
though it was briefly resurrected after
the war improvements in electronic
guidance systems eventually saw the idea
shells for good had pigeon kind shared a
collective Consciousness there surely
would have been a giant coup of relief
Americans Ingenuity and inventiveness in
building bat bombs and pitching guided
missiles was really impressive but they
weren't the only ones blowing up animals
in the name of military progress the
British also got in on the ACT though
true to form their attempts weren't
quite so Grand as those across the pond
the Brits specifically the British
Special Operations executive made all
manner of ingenious devices during the
second world war but if you're picturing
Q handing 007 and elegantly understated
gerbil watch
you might be disappointed whilst the
Americans developed their blazing bath
bombs and puts their pigeon Pilots
through their Paces we Brits were busy
coming up with a exploding rats allow me
to explain this highly intricate device
take a dead rat slice it open and fill
its lifeless carcass with plastic
explosives
and sew it back up voila you've just
made your very own exploding rat time to
take over the world
okay so the point of the exploding Grant
might not be all that obvious at first
the fact it's already dead means you
still need a person to take it to the
place you want to blow up
at which point you could just do away
with the rat carcass entirely
but here's where the clever bit comes in
the explosive rats were intended to be
left in and around factories and other
key production facilities specifically
those with large industrial furnaces
dead rats are a fairly common sight in
those kinds of places and when found
they're disposed of but you can't just
dump a dead animal in the Dustbin and
forget about it not if you have a sense
of smell
it's much better to deal with the
problem once and for all by shoveling
the carcass into a furnace with a normal
dead rat that'd be fine but if your
rigor mortis rodent happens to contain
several grams of plastic explosive
well there goes your factory
the idea was genius in its Simplicity
and it had some success though not as
intended the very first batch of stinky
and rather dangerous rodents was
intercepted by the Nazis before its
occupants could reach their destinations
as a result not one single furry death
bomb was ever thrown into a furnace but
the Discover free of a crate full of
exploding rats was enough to set Nazi
High command into meltdown as they
imagine God knows how many
non-intercepted containers making their
way across the third rank a colossal rat
hunting sued and so much time and money
was spent searching for exploding rats
that the operation was deemed a
resounding success
since the second world war animals in
Warfare have come along in Leaps and
Bounds today there are rumors of
programs using Dolphins seals and even
spy sharks but regardless of how
sophisticated these weapons become they
still rely on innocent creatures being
forcibly conscripted into the
unfortunate task of fighting our Wars
for us
it doesn't seem fair really someone
should call the military wing of the
rspca thanks for watching